thankful for that
thank you mayor cooper for your support
thank you governor lee
thank you to the nashville convention
and visitors corporation
and the national chamber of commerce all
of you
but most of all i just want to say a
heartfelt thank you to the students of
belmont
university for sharing their campus with
you all of you this week
uh this has been a complicated and
unusual
semester to say the least i want to
thank the ryman
hospitalities corporation for taking
several hundred of our students and
letting them stay overnight last night
and through the day-to-day i was worried
the students would be complaining about
that
actually they say they don't want to
come back
they have a water park out there and all
but we're going to get them back
but our students have embraced the
challenge of living
safely together and we simply couldn't
have done that without them
you're probably wondering who these two
people are that are standing here beside
me
well this is molly deakins and this is
kendra turner
they co-chaired the student volunteer
group of 250 students
who made this thing happen here at
belmont university and i'm so grateful
to them thank you and thank all the
belmont
volunteers for what you've done here
and finally i have to say this i've
prayed enough about this happening
that it'd be totally disingenuous if i
didn't say thank you god
that this is about to happen god bless
america thank you
you
the operator for this evening's debate
is kristen welker of
nbc news
good evening everyone good evening
thank you so much for being here it is
such an honor for me to moderate this
debate tonight the final
debate i want to welcome the first
family and the first lady we're so glad
and thankful that you are feeling better
i want to welcome the biden family dr
jill biden thank you all
for being here tonight we are so excited
we're looking forward to
a really robust discussion and the only
thing i would reiterate
are the cpd guidelines that when the
candidates are talking please hold any
applause or any other reactions except
of course when they walk out make sure
you cheer and loud and applause so that
everyone can hear you
thank you for having me this is really
the honor of a lifetime
i am gonna sit down and just get
organized and get
settled and the show will start very
soon
thank you for being here
thank you
time
good evening from belmont university in
nashville tennessee
i'm kristen welker of nbc news and i
welcome you to the final 2020
presidential debate
between president donald j trump and
former vice president joe biden
tonight's debate is sponsored by the
commission on presidential debates
it is conducted under health and safety
protocols
designed by the commission's health
security advisor
the audience here in the hall has
promised to remain silent
no cheers boos or other interruptions
except
right now as we welcome to the stage
former vice president joe biden
and president donald j trump
[Applause]
and i do want to say a very good evening
to both of you
this debate will cover six major topics
at the beginning of each section each
candidate will have two minutes
uninterrupted
to answer my first question the debate
commission will then turn
on their microphone only when it is
their turn to answer
and the commission will turn it off
exactly when the two minutes have
expired
after that both microphones will remain
on but on behalf of the voters i'm going
to ask you to please speak one at a time
the goal is for you to hear each other
and for the american people to hear
every word of what you both have to say
and so with that if you're ready let's
start
and we will begin with the fight against
the coronavirus president trump the
first question is for you
the country is heading into a dangerous
new phase more than 40
000 americans are in the hospital
tonight with covid including
record numbers here in tennessee and
since the two of you last
shared a stage sixteen thousand
americans have died from covid
so please be specific how would you lead
the country during this
next stage of the coronavirus crisis two
minutes uninterrupted
so as you know 2.2 million people
modeled out were expected to die we
closed up
the greatest economy in the world in
order to fight
this horrible disease that came from
china it's a worldwide pandemic it's all
over the world you see the spikes in
europe
and many other places right now if you
notice the
mortality rate is down 85 percent
the excess mortality rate is way down
and much lower than almost any other
country
and we're fighting it and we're fighting
it hard there is a spike there was a
spike in florida and
it's now gone there was a very big spike
in texas
it's now gone there was a very big spike
in arizona it's now gone
and there are some spikes and surges and
other places they will soon be gone
we have a vaccine that's coming it's
ready it's
going to be announced within weeks and
it's going to be delivered we have
operation warp speed which is the
military is going to distribute the
vaccine
i can tell you from personal experience
that
i was in the hospital i had it and i got
better and i will tell you that
i had something that they gave me a
therapeutic
i guess they would call it some people
could say it was a cure
but i was in for a short period of time
and i got better very fast or i wouldn't
be here tonight
and now they say i'm immune whether it's
four months or a lifetime nobody's been
able to say that but
i'm immune more and more people are
getting better we have a problem that's
a worldwide problem this is a worldwide
problem
but i've been congratulated by the heads
of many countries on what we've been
able to do
with the if you if you take a look at
what we've done in terms of
goggles and masks and gowns and
everything else
and in particular ventilators we're now
making ventilators
all over the world thousands and
thousands a month distributing them
all over the world it will go away and
as i say we're rounding the turn we're
rounding the corner it's going away
okay former vice president biden to you
how would you lead the country out of
this crisis
you have two minutes uninterrupted 220
000 americans dead
you hear nothing else i say tonight hear
this
anyone is responsible for not taking
control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain as president of
the united states of america
we're in a situation where there are a
thousand deaths a day
now a thousand deaths a day and there
are over
70 000 new cases per day
compared to what's going on in europe
as the new england medical journal said
they're starting from a very
low rate we're starting from a very high
rate
the expectation is we'll have another
200
000 americans dead be timed between now
and the end of the year
if we just wore these masks the
president's own advisors have told them
we could save a hundred thousand lives
and we're in a circumstance where the
president thus far and still has
no plan no comprehensive plan
what i would do is make sure we have
everyone encouraged to wear
a mask all the time i would make sure we
move in the direction of rapid testing
investing in rapid testing i would make
sure that we
set up national standards as to how to
open up schools and open up businesses
so they can be safe
and give them the wherewithal the
financial resources to be able to do
that
we're in a situation now where the new
england medical journal one of the
serious most serious journals in the
in the whole world said for the first
time ever that this the way this
president has responded to this crisis
has been absolutely tragic and so folks
i will take care of this i will end this
i will make sure we have a plan
president trump i'd like to follow up
with you and your comments you talked
about taking a therapeutic i assume
you're referencing
regeneron you also said a vaccine will
be coming within weeks
is that a guarantee is no it's not a
guarantee but it will be by the end of
the year but i think it has a good
chance there are two companies i think
within a matter of weeks
and it will be distributed very quickly
can you tell us which companies
johnson johnson is doing very well
moderner is doing very well
pfizer is doing very well and we have
numerous others
then we also have others that we're
working on very closely with other
countries in particular europe
let me follow up with you because this
is new information you have said a
vaccine is coming soon within weeks now
your own officials say
it could take well into 2021 at the
earliest for enough americans to get
vaccinated and even then they say the
country will be wearing masks and
distancing
into 2022. is your timeline realistic
no i think my timeline is going to be
more accurate i don't know that they're
counting on the military the way i do
but we have our generals lined up one in
particular that's the
head of logistics and this is a very
easy distribution for him he's ready to
go as soon as we have the vaccine
and we expect to have a hundred million
vials as soon as we have the vaccine
he's ready to go
vice president biden your reaction and
just 40 percent of americans say they
would definitely agree to take a
coronavirus vaccine
if it was approved by the government
what steps would you take to give
americans confidence
in a vaccine if it were approved make
sure it's totally
transparent have the scientists of the
world see it
know it look at it go through all the
processes and by the way
he's this is the same fellow told you
this is going to end by easter last time
this is the same fella who told you that
don't worry we're going to end this by
the summer we're about to go into a dark
winter
a dark winter and he has no clear plan
and there's no prospect
that there's going to be a vaccine
available for the majority of the
american people before the middle of
next year
president trump your reaction he says
you have no plan to have a dark winter
and
at all we're opening up our country
we've learned and studied and understand
the disease
which we didn't at the beginning when i
closed and banned
china from coming in heavily infected
and then ultimately europe
but china was in january months later he
was saying i was xenophobic i did it too
soon now he's saying oh
i should have i should have you know
moved quicker but he didn't move quicker
he was months behind
me many months behind me and frankly
he ran the h1 n1 swine flu
and it was a total disaster far less
lethal but
it was a total disaster had that had
this kind of
numbers 700 000 people would be dead
right now
but it was a far less lethal disease
look his own person who ran that for him
who as you know was his uh chief of
staff
said it was catastrophic it was horrible
we didn't know what we were doing now he
comes up and he tells us how to do this
also everything that he said about the
way every single move that he said we
should make
that's what we've done we've done all of
it but he was way behind us
vice president biden your response my
response is he is xenophobic but not
because he shut down
access from china and he did it late
after 40 countries had already done that
in addition to that what he did he made
sure that we had 44 people that were in
there
in china trying to get to wuhan to
determine what exactly the source was
what did the president say in january
he said no he said this is he's being
transparent
the president of china is being
transparent we owe more debt of
gratitude we ought to we have to thank
him
and and then what happened was we
started talking about using
the defense act to make sure we go out
and get whatever is needed
out there to protect people and again i
go back to this
he had nothing he did virtually nothing
and then he gets out of the hospital
and he talks about where this is oh
don't worry
it's all going to be over soon come on
there's not another serious scientist in
the world who thinks it's going to be
over soon
president trump your reaction over soon
i say we're learning to live with it we
have no choice we can't lock ourselves
up in a basement like
joe does he has the he has the ability
to lock
himself up i don't know he's obviously
made a lot of money someplace
but he has this thing about living in a
basement people can't do that
by the way i as the president couldn't
do that i'd love to put myself in the
basement or in a beautiful room in the
white house
and go away for a year and a half until
it disappears i can't do that
and kirsten every every meeting i had
every meeting i had and i'd meet a lot
of families including gold star families
and military families
every meeting i had and i had to meet
that i had to it would be horrible to
have cancelled everything
i said you know this is dangerous and
you catch it and you know i caught it
i learned a lot i learned a lot great
doctors great hospitals
and now i recovered 99.9
of young people recover 99
of people recover we have to recover we
can't close up our nation we have to
open our school
and we can't close up our nation or
you're not going to have
a nation and of course the cdc has said
young people
can get sick with covet 19 and can pass
it vice president biden i want to talk
broadly about strategy
though you have to respond to that 30
seconds please and i have a question
no number one he says that we're uh you
know we're learning to live with it
people are learning to die with it you
folks home will have an empty chair at
the kitchen table this morning
that man or wife going to bed tonight
and reaching over to try to touch their
out of habit where their wife or husband
was is gone
learning to live with it come on we're
dying with it
because he has never said he said it's
dangerous
when's the last time is it really
dangerous still are we dangerous you
tell the people it's dangerous now what
should they do about the danger
and you say i take no responsibility let
me talk about your
excuse me i take it i take full
responsibility
it's not my fault that it came here it's
china's fault and you know what it's not
joe's fault that it came here either
it's china's fault they kept it from
going into the rest of china for the
most part
but they didn't keep it from coming out
to the world including europe and
ourselves
vice president biden the fact is that
when we knew it was coming
when it hit what happened what did the
president say
he said don't worry it's going to go
away be gone by easter don't worry the
warm weather don't worry maybe inject
bleach he said he was kidding when he
said that a lot of people thought it was
serious
a whole range of things the president
has said even today
he thinks we are in control we're about
to lose 200 000 more people
president trump look perhaps just to
finish this
i was kidding on that but just to finish
this
when i closed he said i shouldn't have
closed
and that went on for months nancy pelosi
said the same thing she was dancing on
the streets in chinatown in san
francisco
but when i closed he said this is a
terrible thing you're xenophobic i think
he called me racist even
and because i was closing it to china
now he says i should have closed it
earlier
it just joe it doesn't work i didn't say
either of those things you certainly did
i talked about a xenophobia in a
different context it wasn't about
closing the border to chinese coming to
the united states all right i want to
talk about both of your different
strategies to handle i thought
i shouldn't have closed the border
that's obvious
is that do you want to respond to that
quickly vice president okay
let's talk about your different
strategies toward dealing with this mr
vice president you suggested you would
support new shutdowns if scientists
recommended it what do you say to
americans who are fearful that the cost
of shutdowns the impact on the economy
the higher rates of hunger depression
domestic and substance abuse outweighs
the risk of exposure to the virus
what i would say is i'm going to shut
down the virus not the country
it's his ineptitude the cause that
caused the country to have to shut down
in large part
why businesses have gone under why
schools are closed why so many people
have lost their
living and why they're concerned those
other concerns are real that's why
he should have been instead of in a sand
trap in his golf course he should have
been negotiating
with nancy pelosi and the rest of the
democrats and republicans about
what to do about the acts they were
passing for billions of dollars to make
sure people had the capacity
but you haven't ruled out more shutdowns
well no i'm not shutting down today but
there are
look they need standards the standard is
if you have a reproduction rate in a
community
that's above a certain level everybody
says slow up
more social distancing do not open bars
and do not open gymnasiums
do not open until you get this under
control under more control
but when you do open give the people the
capacity to be able to open and have the
capacity
to do it safely for example schools
schools they need a lot of money to open
they need to
deal with ventilation systems they need
to deal with smaller classes
more teachers more pods and he's refused
to support that money
or at least up to now let's talk about
schools president trump i think we have
to respond if i might
please and then i have a phone thank you
and i appreciate that look all he does
is talk about shutdowns but forget about
him
his democrat governors cuomo in new york
you look at what's going on in
california you look at pennsylvania
north carolina
democrats democrats all they're shut
down so tight
and they're dying they're dying and he
supports all these people
all he talks about is shutdowns no we're
not going to shut down and we have to
open our schools
and it's like as an example i have a
young son he also
tested positive by the time i spoke to
the doctor the second time he was fine
it just went away
young people i guess it's their immune
system let me follow up with you
president trump you've demanded schools
open in person and insist they can do it
safely but just yesterday
boston became the latest city to move
its public school system entirely online
after a coronavirus spike
what is your message to parents who
worry that sending their children to
school will endanger not only their kids
but also their teachers and families i
want to open the schools
the transmittal rate to the teachers is
very small but i want to open the
schools we have to open our country
we're not going to have a country
you can't do this we can't keep this
country close this is a
massive country with a massive economy
people are losing their jobs they're
committing suicide
there's depression alcohol drugs at a
level that nobody's ever seen before
there's abuse tremendous abuse we have
to open our country
you know i've said it often the cure
cannot be worse
than the problem itself and that's
what's happening
and he wants to close down he'll close
down the country if
one person in our in our massive
bureaucracy says we should close it down
vice president biden you're simply not
true
we ought to be able to walk and chew gum
at the same time we ought to be able to
safely
open but when they need resources to
open
you need to be able to for example if
you're going to open a business
have social distancing within the
business you need to have if you have a
restaurant you need to have
plexiglas dividers so people cannot
infect one another you need to be in a
position where you can take
testing rapidly and know whether a
person is
in fact infected you need to be able to
trace you need to be able to provide
all the resources that are needed to do
this and that is not
inconsistent with saying that
what we're going to make sure that we
open safely and by the way
all you teachers out there not that many
of you are going to die so don't worry
about it
so don't worry about it come on
president trump let me follow up with
you quickly by the way i will say this
if you go and look at what's happened to
new york it's a ghost town
it's a ghost town and when you talk
about plexiglass these are restaurants
that are dying
these are businesses with no money
putting a plexiglass is unbelievably
expensive
and it's not the answer i mean you're
going to sit there in a cubicle wrapped
around with
plastic it's these are businesses that
are dying joe you can't do that to
people
you just can't take a look at new york
and what's happened to my
wonderful city for for so many years i
loved it it was vibrant it's dying
everyone's leaving new york
take a look that's what new york has
done in terms of turning the curve down
in terms of the number of people dying
and i don't look at this in terms of the
way he does blue states and red
states they're all the united states and
look at the states that are having such
a spike
in the coronavirus they're the red
states
they're the states in the midwest of the
states in the upper midwest that's where
the spike is occurring significantly
but they're all americans they're all
americans and what we have to do is say
wear these masks number one make sure we
get the help that the businesses need
that has
monies already been passed to do that
it's been out there since the beginning
of the summer
and nothing's happened president new
york has lost
more than 40 000 people eleven thousand
people
in nursing president trump say spike
take a look at what's happening in
pennsylvania
where they've had it closed take a look
at what's happening with your friend
in michigan where her husband's the only
one allowed to do anything
it's been like a prison now it was just
ruled unconstitutional
take a look at north carolina they're
having spikes
and they've been closed and they're
getting killed financially
we can't let that happen joe you can't
let that happen
we have to open up and we understand the
disease
we have to protect our seniors we have
to protect our elderly we have to
protect
especially our seniors with heart
problems and diabetes problems
and we will protect we have the best
testing in the world by far
that's why we have so many cases let me
follow up with you before we move on to
our next section president trump this
week you called dr anthony fauci the
nation's best known infectious disease
expert
quote a disaster you described him and
other medical experts as quote
idiots if you're not listening to them
who are you listening to
i'm listening to all of them including
anthony i get along very well with
anthony but
he did say don't wear masks he did say
as you know this is not going to be a
problem
i think he's a democrat but that's okay
he said this is not going to be a
problem
we are not going to have a problem at
all when joe says that
i said anthony fauci said and others and
many others and i'm not
knocking him a lot nobody knew look
nobody knew what this thing was nobody
knew where it was coming from what it
was we've learned a lot
but anthony said don't wear masks now he
wants to wear masks
anthony also said if you look back exact
words here's his exact words
this is no problem this is going to go
away soon so he's allowed to make
mistakes he happens to be a good person
vice president biden your response
quickly and then we're going to move on
to the next section our response is that
think about what the president knew in
january and didn't tell the american
people
he was told this was a serious virus
that spread in the air
and it was much worse than much worse
than the flu
he went on record and said to one of
your colleagues
recorded that in fact he knew how
dangerous it was but he didn't want to
tell us
he didn't want to tell us because he
didn't want us to panic he didn't want
us
americans don't panic he panicked but
guess what in the meantime we find out
in the new york times the other day that
in fact
his folks went to wall street and said
this is a really dangerous thing
and a memo out of that meeting not from
his administration
but from some of the brokers said sell
short because we've got to get moving
it's a dangerous problem well this is
i'm going to give you 30 seconds to
respond and then
the wall street i don't know somebody
went to wall street you're the one that
takes all the money from wall street i
don't take it
you have raised a lot of money
tremendous amounts of money
and every time you raise money deals are
made you know i could raise so much more
money
as president and as somebody that knows
most of those people
i could call the heads of wall street
the heads of every company in america
i would blow away every record but i
don't want to do that because it puts me
in a bad position
and then you bring up wall street you
shouldn't be bringing up wall street
because you're the one that takes the
money from wall street not me
i could blow away your records that like
you wouldn't believe we don't need money
we have plenty of money in fact
we beat hillary clinton with a tiny
fraction of the money that she was able
to all right gentlemen
don't tell me about this average
contribution 43 all right we're going to
move on to our next section which is
national
security and i do want to start with the
security of our elections and some
breaking news from overnight just last
night
top intelligence officials confirmed
again that both russia and iran
are working to influence this election
both countries have obtained u.s voter
registration information these officials
say
and iran sent intimidating messages to
florida
voters this question goes to you mr vice
president what would you do
to put an end to this threat you have
two minutes uninterrupted
i made it clear and i asked everyone
else to take the pledge
i made it clear that any country no
matter who it is that interferes in
american elections
will pay a price they will pay a price
it's been overwhelmingly clear this
election i won't even get into the last
one
this election that russia has been
involved china has been involved to some
degree and now we learn that
that that iran is involved they will pay
a price if i'm elected they're
interfering with american
sovereignty that's what's going on right
now they're interfering with american
sovereignty
and to the best of my knowledge i don't
think the president said anything to
putin about it
i don't think he's stuck with him a lot
i don't think he said a word i don't
know why he hadn't said a word to putin
about it
and i don't know what he has recently
said if anything to the iranians my
guess is he'd probably be more outspoken
with regard to the iranians
but the point is this folks we are in a
situation where we have foreign
company countries trying to interfere in
the outcome of our election
his old own national security adviser
told him that
what is happening with his buddy well i
won't go
oh i will his buddy rudy giuliani he's
being used as a russian pawn
he's being fed information that is
russian
that is not true and then what happens
nothing happens
and then you find out that everything is
going on here
about russia is wanting to make sure
that i do not
get elected the next president united
states because they know i know
them and they know me i don't understand
why
this president is unwilling to take on
putin when he's actually
paying bounties to kill american
soldiers in afghanistan
when he's engaged in activities that are
trying to destabilize all of
nato i don't know why he doesn't do it
but it's worth
asking the question why isn't that being
done
any country that interferes with us will
in fact pay a price because they're
affecting our sovereignty
president trump same question to you let
me let me ask the question you're gonna
have two minutes to respond for two
elections in a row now there has been
substantial interference from foreign
adversaries
what would you do in your next term to
put an end to this two minutes
let me respond to the first part as joe
answered joe got three and a half
million dollars from russia
and it came through putin because he was
very friendly with the
former mayor of moscow and it was the
mayor of moscow's wife and
you got three and a half million dollars
your family got three and a half million
dollars and
you know someday you're gonna have to
explain why did you get three and a half
i never got any money from russia i
don't get money from russia
now about your thing last night i knew
all about that
and through john who is john ratliff
who's fantastic dni
he said the one thing that's common to
both of them
they both want you to lose because there
has been nobody tougher to russia
with between the sanctions nobody
tougher than me on russia
between the sanctions between all of
what i've done with nato you know i've
got the nato countries to put up
an extra 130 billion going to 420
billion dollars a year
that's to guard against russia i sold
while he was selling pillows and sheets
i sold tank busters to ukraine there has
been nobody
tougher than on russia than donald trump
and i'll tell you they were so bad they
took over the
the submarine port you remember that
very well
during your term during you and barack
obama
they took over a big part of what should
have been ukraine you handed it to him
but you were getting a lot of money from
russia they were paying you a lot of
money
and they probably still are but now with
what came out today
it's even worse all of the emails the
emails the horrible emails of the kind
of money that you were raking in you and
your family
and joe you were vice president when
some of this was happening
and it should have never happened and i
think you owe an explanation to the
american people
why is it somebody just had a news
conference a little while
ago who was essentially supposed to work
with you and your family
but what he said was damning and
regardless of me i think you have to
clean it up and talk to the american
people maybe you can do it right now
vice president biden you may respond and
then i do want to follow up on the
election security i have not
taken a penny from any foreign source
ever
in my life we learned that this
president paid
50 times the tax in china has a secret
bank account
with china does business in china
and in fact is talking about me taking
money
i have not taken a single penny from any
country
whatsoever ever number one number two
this is a president i have released all
of my tax returns
22 years go look at them 22 years of my
tax return
you have not released the single
solitary year of your tax return what
are you hiding
why are you unwilling the foreign
countries are paying you
a lot russia's paying you a lot china's
painting a lot
and your hotels and all your businesses
all around the country
all around the world and china is
building a new road to a new
a golf course you have overseas so
what's going on here why don't release
your tax return or stop talking about
corruption president trump your response
first of all
i called my accountants underwrote it
i'm going to release them as soon as we
can i want to do it and it'll show how
successful how great this company is but
much more importantly than that
people were saying 750 i asked them
a week ago i said what did i pay they
said sir you prepaid
tens of millions of dollars i prepaid my
tax tens over the last
number of years tens of millions of
dollars i prepaid
because at some point they think it's an
estimate they think i may have to pay
tax
so i already prepaid it nobody told me
that
nobody told you that excuse me and it
wasn't written whenever they write this
they keep talking about 750 which i
think is a filing fee
but let me just tell you i prepaid
millions and millions of dollars in
taxes
number one number two i don't make money
from china you do
i don't make money from ukraine you do i
don't make money from russia
you made three and a half million
dollars joe and your son gave you
they even have a statement that we have
to give 10 percent
to the big man you're the big man i
think i don't know maybe you're not
but you're the big man i think your son
said we have to give 10 percent to the
big man
joe what's that all about it's terrible
all right gentlemen i want to ask you
both some questions
about all of this but i'm going to let
you both respond very quickly
you just said you spoke to your
accountant about potentially releasing
your taxes did he tell you when you can
release them do you
have the deadline
worse than the tea party got treated
because i have a lot of people in there
deep down in the irs they treat me
horribly we made a deal it was all
settled until i decided to run for
president
i get treated very badly by the irs very
unfairly
but we had a deal all done as soon as
we're completed with the deal i want to
release it
but i have paid millions and millions of
dollars
and i it's worse than paying i paid in
advance it's called
pre-paying your taxes i paid in i want
to ask you both about
questions regarding your potential
foreign entanglements and questions that
have been raised to give you both a
chance to talk about this more broadly
respond very quickly and then i'll get
to my question why did he's been saying
this for four years
show us just show us stop playing around
you've been saying for four years you're
gonna release your taxes nobody knows mr
president what they do know
is you're not paying your taxes or
you're paying taxes that are so low
when last time he said what he paid he
said i only pay that little because i'm
smart
i know how to game the system come on
come on folks so president trump and
then i want to get to two questions to
both of you guys
i was put through a phony witch hunt
for three years it started
before i even got elected they spied on
my campaign
no president should ever have to go
through what i went through let me just
say this mueller and 18 angry democrats
and fbi agents all over the place spent
48 million dollars
they went through everything i had
including my tax returns
and they found absolutely no collusion
and nothing wrong
48 million i guarantee you if i spent 1
million on you jill i could find plenty
wrong
because the kind of things that you've
done and the kind of monies that your
family has taken
i mean your brother made money in iraq
millions of dollars
your other brother made a fortune and
it's all through you joe and they say
you get some of it
and you do live very well you have
houses all over the place you live very
well
all right gentlemen let me just ask some
questions about all of this broadly vice
president biden there have been
questions about the work your son has
done in china
and for a ukrainian energy company when
you were vice president in retrospect
was anything about those relationships
inappropriate or unethical
nothing was unethical here's what the
deal
with regard to ukraine we had this whole
question about whether or not because he
was on the board i later learned of a
barisma
a company that somehow i had done
something wrong
yet every single solitary person when he
was going through his impeachment
testifying under oath who worked for him
said i did my
job impeccably i carried out u.s policy
not one single solitary thing was out of
line
not a single thing number one number two
the guy who got in trouble in ukraine
was this guy trying to bribe
the ukrainian government to say
something negative about me
which they would not do and did not do
because it never
ever ever happened my son has not made
money in terms of this thing about what
are you talking about
china i have not had the only guy who
made money from china
is this guy he's the only one nobody
else has made money from china
let me let me ask my question to you
could i just one one thing very quickly
his son
didn't have a job for a long time was
sadly no longer in
the military service i won't get into
that and he didn't have a job
as soon as he became vice president
barisma not the best look
not the best reputation in the world i
hear they paid him 183
000 a month listen to this 183
and they gave him a three million dollar
upfront payment all right and he had no
energy i'm going to let the vice
president sponsor that quickly and then
i need to get to a question to you very
basis for that everybody investigated
that no one said anything he did was
wrong in ukraine
okay president trump this is for you
since you took office you've never
divested from your business you've
personally promoted your properties
abroad
a report this week which was referenced
does indicate that your company has a
bank account in china
so how can voters know that you don't
have any foreign conflicts of interest i
have many bank accounts and they're all
listed and they're all over the place i
mean i was a businessman
doing business the bank account you're
referring to
which is everybody knows about it it's
listed the bank account was in
2013. that's what it was it was opened
in two
it was closed in 2015 i believe
and then i decided because i was going
to do i was thinking about doing a deal
in china like
millions of other people i was thinking
about it and i decided i'm not going to
do it
didn't like it i decided not to do it
had an account open
and i closed it okay excuse me and then
unlike him
where he's vice president and he does
business
i then decided to run for president
after that that was before
so i closed it before i even ran for
president
let alone became president big
difference he is
the vice president of the united states
and his son his brother
and his other brother are getting rich
they're like a vacuum cleaner they're
sucking
up everything thank you move on i do
want to ask you
uh vice president biden about china
let's talk about china more broadly
there have of course president trump has
said that they should pay
for not being fully transparent in
regards to the coronavirus
if you were president would you make
china pay and please be specific what
would that look like
what i'd make china do is play by the
international rules
not like he has done he has caused the
deficit of china to go up
not down with china up not down
we are making sure that in order to do
business in china you have to give
all your intellectual property you have
to get a have a partner in china it's 51
we would not do that at all number one
number two we're in a situation where
china would have to play by the rules
internationally as well
when i met with xi that and uh when i
was still vice president he said we're
setting up air identification zones in
the
in the south china sea you can't fly
through them i said we're going to fly
through them we just flew b-52 b-1
bombers
through it we're not going to pay
attention they have to play by the rules
and what's he do he embraces guys like
the thugs like in north korea and
and the chinese president and putin and
others
and he pokes his fingers now of all of
our friends all of our allies
we make up only we're 25
25 of the world's economy we need to be
having the rest of our friends
with us saying to china these are the
rules you play by them or you're going
to pay the price for not paying by them
economically that's the way i will run
it and that's what we did
and upholding steel tariffs and a range
of other things and we were president
vice president
all right let's talk about north korea
let me know i have to respond to that
okay very quickly and then we're going
to move on with three and a half dollars
from china
after spending ten minutes in office and
being in air force two
number one number two there's a very
strong
email talking about your family wanting
to make
10 million dollars a year for
introductions president trump
on china policy though what's your
number what are you gonna do
what specifically are you going to do to
make china pay you've said you're going
to
pay china is paying they're paying
billions and billions of dollars i just
gave 28 billion
i just gave 28 billion dollars to our
farmers taxpayers china
guess what taxpayers money income yeah
you know the taxpayer is it's called
china
china 28 billion and you know what they
did to pay it joe
they devalued their currency and they
also paid up and you know who got the
money our farmers are great farmers
because they were targeted
you never charge them anything also i
charged them 25 on dumped steel
because they were killing our steel
indus we were not going to have a steel
index okay
and now we have a stealing okay vice
president biden your response please
our response is look this isn't about
there's a reason why he's
bringing up all this malarkey there's a
reason for it
he doesn't want to talk about the the
the substance of issues
it's not about his family and my family
it's about your family
and your family is hurting badly if
you're making less than
if you're a middle class family you're
getting hurt
badly right now you're sitting at the
kitchen table this morning deciding
well we can't get new tires they're bald
because we have to wait another month or
so
or are we going to be able to pay the
mortgage or who's going to tell her she
can't go back to
to community college they're the
decisions you're making
in the middle class families like i grew
up in scranton and clemont
they're in trouble we should be talking
about your families but that's the last
thing he wants to talk about
i wanted to say i want to talk about
north korea i didn't want to turn to
10 seconds mr president ten seconds
political statement
let's get off this china thing and then
he looks the family around the table
everything
just a typical politician when i see
that let's talk about not a difficult
politician okay
that's why i got elected let's get off
the subject of china let's talk around
sitting around the table
come on joe you can do better we're
going to talk about north korea now
president trump you've met with north
korean leader kim jong-un three times
you've talked about your beautiful
letters with him you've touted the fact
that there hasn't been a war
or a long-range missile test and yet
north korea recently rolled out its
biggest ever intercontinental ballistic
missile
and continues to develop its nuclear
arsenal do you see that as a betrayal of
the relationship you forged just 30
seconds here because we need to get on
to the next so
when i met with barack obama we sat in
the white house
right at the beginning had a great
conversation was supposed to be 15
minutes and it was well over an hour
he said the biggest problem we have with
north is north korea
he indicated we will be in a war with
north korea guess what
it would be a nuclear war and he does
have plenty of nuclear capability
in the meantime i have a very good
relationship with him different kind of
a guy but he probably thinks the same
thing about me
we have a different kind of a
relationship we have a very good
relationship
and there's no war and you know about
two months ago
he broke into a certain area they said
oh there's going to be trouble he said
no they're not
because he's not going to do that and i
was right look instead of being in a war
where millions of people soul you know
is 25 miles away
millions and millions 32 million people
in seoul millions of people would be
dead right now president trump that's 30
seconds
vice president biden to you north korea
conducted four nuclear tests under the
obama administration
why do you think you would be able to
reign in this persistent threat
because i'd make it clear which we were
making clear to china they had to be
part of the deal
because here's the re i made it clear
and as a spokesperson administration
when i went to china
that they said why are you moving your
missile defense up so close
why are you moving more forces here why
you continue to do
uh um military maneuvers with south
korea
i said because north korea is a problem
and we're going to continue to do it so
we can control them we're going to make
sure we can control them and make sure
they cannot hurt us
and so if you want to do something about
it step up and help if not
it's going to continue what has he done
he's legitimized north korea
he's talked about his good buddy who's a
thug a thug
and he talks about how we're better off
and they are have much more capable
missiles able to reach
u.s territory much more easily than ever
did before let me follow up with you
vice president biden you've said you
wouldn't meet with kim jong-un without
preconditions are there any conditions
under which you would meet with him
on the condition that he would agree
that he would be drawing down his
nuclear capacity to get that the korean
peninsula should be nuclear free zone
all right let's move on to american
families they tried very quickly
they tried to meet with him he wouldn't
do it he didn't like
obama he didn't like him he wouldn't do
it okay you got to give him a picture
respond to that
and that's okay you know what north
korea we're not in a war
we have a good relationship you know
people understand having a good
relationship
with leaders of other countries we have
a lot of questions to get to know that's
right
and we had a good relationship with
hitler before he in fact invaded
europe the rest of europe come on is the
reason
he would not meet with president obama
is because president obama said
we're going to talk about
denuclearization we're not going to
legitimize you we're going to continue
to put stronger and stronger
sanctions on you that's why he wouldn't
meet with us
all right move on let's just move on and
talk about that
chris president trump okay they left me
a mess
north korea was a mess and in fact if
you remember the first two or three
months questions tonight
it was a very dangerous period in my
first three months before
we sort of worked things out a little
bit there was a very
they left us a mess and obama would be i
think
the first to say it was the single
biggest problem he thought
that our country okay let's move on to
american families and the economy
on one of the issues that's most
important to them is health care as you
both know
today there was a key vote on a new
supreme court justice amy coney barrett
and health care is at the center of her
confirmation fight
over 20 million americans get their
health insurance through the affordable
care act
it's headed to the supreme court and
your administration mr president is
advocating for the court to overturn it
if the supreme court does overturn that
law those 20 million americans could
lose their health insurance almost
overnight so what would you do
if those people have their health
insurance taken away you have two
minutes uninterrupted
first of all i've already done something
that nobody thought was possible
through the legislature i terminated the
individual mandate
that is the worst part of obamacare as
we call it
the individual mandate where you have to
pay a fortune for the privilege of
not having to pay for bad health
insurance i terminated
it's gone now it's in court because
obamacare is no good
but then i made a decision run it as
well as you can to my people
great people run it as well as you can i
could have gone the other route and made
everybody very unhappy
they ran it premiums are down
everything's down here's the problem
no matter how well you run it it's no
good what we'd like to do
is terminate it we have the individual
mandate
done i don't know that it's going to
work if we don't win
we will have to run it and we'll have
obamacare but it'll be better run
but it no longer is obamacare because
without the individual mandate
it's much different pre-existing
conditions will always stay
what i would like to do is a much better
health care much better
we'll always protect people with
pre-existing so i'd like to terminate
obamacare come up with a brand new
beautiful health care
the democrats will do it because
there'll be tremendous pressure on them
and we might even have the house by that
time
and i think we're going to win the house
okay you'll see but i think we're going
to win the house
but come up with a better health care
always protecting people
with pre-existing conditions and one
thing very important we have 180 million
people out there
that have great private health care far
more than we're talking about with
obamacare
joe biden is going to terminate all of
those policies these are people that
love their health care
people that have been successful middle
income people
been successful they have 180
million plants 180 million people
families
under what he wants to do which will
basically be socialized medicine he
won't even have a choice
they want to terminate 180 million plans
we have done an incredible job on health
care
and we're going to do even better okay
vice president biden yes this is for you
your health care plan calls for building
on obamacare so my question is what is
your plan
if the law is ruled unconstitutional by
the supreme court you have two minutes
uninterrupted
what i'm going to do is pass obamacare
with a public option
become biden care the public option is
an option that says that
if you in fact do not have the
wherewithal to be if you
qualify for medicaid and you do not have
the wherewithal
then your state to get medicaid you
automatically are enrolled
providing competition for insurance
companies that's what's going to happen
secondly
we're going to make sure we reduce the
premiums and reduce drug prices
by making sure that there's competition
that doesn't exist now by allowing
the medicare to negotiate drug prices
with the insurance companies thirdly
the idea that i want to eliminate
private insurance the reason why i had
such a fight
for with 20 candidates for the
nomination was
i support private insurance that's why
i did not one single person with private
insurance
would lose their insurance under my plan
nor
did they under obamacare they did not
lose their insurance
unless they chose they wanted to go to
something else lastly
we're going to make sure in a situation
that we actually
protect pre-existing there's no way he
can protect pre-existing conditions
none zero you can't do it in the ether
he's been talking about this for a long
time there is
no he's never come up with a plan i
guess we're going to get the
pre-existing condition plan the same
time
we get the infrastructure plan that we
waited since
17 18 19 and 20. the fact i still have a
few more minutes i know you're getting
anxious
the uh the fact is that the he's already
cost the american people because of this
terrible handling of the covet virus and
economic spillover
10 million people have lost their
private insurance
and he wants to take away 22 million
more people who have it under obamacare
and over 110 million people with
pre-existing conditions
and all the people from covert are going
to have pre-existing conditions
what are they going to do i have a
follow-up for you vice president biden
it relates to something that president
trump said he's accusing you of wanting
socialized medicine what do you say to
people
who have concerns that your health care
plan which includes a government
insurance option takes the country
one step closer to a health care system
run entirely by the government
i say it's ridiculous it's like saying
that you know
we're uh the idea that the fact that
there's a public option that people can
choose
that makes it a socialist plan look the
difference between the president i think
health care is not
a privilege it's a right everyone should
have the right to have affordable health
care
and i am very proud of my plan it's
gotten endorsed by
all the major labor unions as well as as
well as a whole range of other people
who in fact are concerned in the medical
field
this is something that's going to save
people's lives and this is going to give
some
people an opportunity an opportunity to
have health care for their children
how many of you home are worried and
rolling around in bed tonight wondering
what in god's name you're going to do if
you get sick because you've lost your
home insurance your your health
insurance your company's gone under
we have to provide health insurance for
people at an affordable rate and that's
what i do
president trump told me he was here
before 47 years
he didn't do it he was now there as vice
president for eight years and it's not
like it was 25 years ago it was three
and three quarters it was just a little
while ago
right less than four years ago he didn't
do anything
he didn't do it he wants socialized
medicine and it's not that he wants it
his vice president
i mean she is is more liberal
than bernie sanders and wants it even
more bernie sanders wants it
the democrats want it you're going to
have socialized medicine just like you
want to with fracking
we're not going to have fracking we're
going to stop fracking we're going to
stop fracking then he goes to
pennsylvania after he gets to nomination
where he got very lucky to get it
and he goes to pennsylvania and he says
oh we're going to have fracking
and you never ask that question and by
the way so far i respect very much the
way you're handling this i have to
by the way but somebody should ask the
question you can actually he goes for a
year
there will be we have a friend we have
we do have a number of we have a number
of topics right now but that's so weird
we're going to get to we're going to get
to the same thing with socializing
vice president your response please my
response is people deserve to have
affordable health care
period period period period and the
biden care proposal will in fact
provide for that affordable health care
lower premiums what we're going to do is
going to cost some money
it's going to cost over 750 billion
dollars over 10 years to do it
and they're going to have lower premiums
you can buy into the better plans
the cheaper plans lower your premiums
deal with
unders unexpected billing and have your
drug prices drop significantly he keeps
talking about it he hasn't
done a thing for anybody on health care
not a thing just in one hour
and i want to talk about what he says
public health he's talking about
socialized medicine
and when he and and healthcare when he
talks about a public option
he's talking about destroying your
medicare totally destroyed and
destroying your social security
and this whole country will come down
you know bernie sanders tried it
in his state he tried it in a state his
governor was a very liberal governor
they want to make it work
okay
vice president very confused guy he
thinks he's running against somebody
else
he's running against joe biden i beat
all those other people because i
disagreed with them
joe biden he's running against and the
idea that we're in a situation that is
going to destroy medicare
this is the guy that the actuary
medicare said
if in fact at social security if in fact
he continues to
withhold his plan to withhold the tax on
social security
social security will be bankrupt in by
2023
with no way to make up for it this is
the guy who's tried to cut
medicare so i don't i mean the idea that
donald trump
is lecturing me on social security and
medicare
come on he tried to get rid of he tried
to hurt social security years ago
years ago go back and look at the
records he tried to hurt social security
years ago all right let's move but this
is the guy
mr president i have to move on to the
next question
if i'm elected if he's elected the stock
market will crash
okay let's get on to the next question
very quickly
the idea that the stock market is
booming is his only measure of what's
happening
where i come from in scranton and claim
on that people don't live off of the
stock market
just in the uh just in the last three
three years during this crisis
said the the billionaires in this
country made according to
the wall street 700 billion more dollars
700 billion more dollars because that's
his only measure
what happens to the ordinary people out
there what
happens to them let's talk about 401k
401k is a through the roof we're going
to move on or through the roof
and he doesn't come from scranton that's
like one of he
lived there for a short period of time
before
as of tonight more than 12 million
people are out of work
and as of tonight 8 million more
americans have fallen into poverty
and more families are going hungry every
day those hit hardest are women
and people of color they see washington
fighting over a relief bill
mr president why haven't you been able
to get them the help they need 30
seconds here
because nancy pelosi doesn't want to
approve it i do but you're the president
i do but i still have to get
unfortunately that's one of the reasons
i think we're going to take over the
house because of her
nancy pelosi doesn't want to approve
anything because she'd love to have some
victories
on a date called november 3rd nancy
pelosi does not want to approve it
we are ready willing and able to do
something don't forget we've
already approved three plans and it's
gone through including the democrats in
all fairness
this one she doesn't want it's near the
election because she thinks it helps her
politically
i think it hurts her politically all
right mr vice president
the republican leader in the united
states senate said he can't pass it
he will not be able to pass it he does
not have republican votes
why isn't he talking to his republican
friends let me follow up with you vice
president we made a deal
let me let me ask vice president biden a
question you are the leader of the
democratic party
why have you not pushed the democrats to
get a deal for the american people well
i have and they have pushed it look they
passed this act
all the way back in the beginning of the
summer this is like it's not new
it's been out there this heroes act has
been sitting there
and look at what's happening when i was
in charge of the recovery act with 800
billion dollars
i was able to get 145 billion dollars to
local communities
that have to balance their budgets in
states that have to balance the budget
so then
have to fire fire to have to fire
firefighters
teachers first responders law
enforcement officers so they can keep
their cities and counties running he
will not support that they have not
done a thing for them and mitch
mcconnell said let him go bankrupt
let him go bankrupt come on what's the
matter bill that was passed in the house
was a bailout of badly run high
crime democrat all run by democrats
cities and states
it was a way of getting a lot of money
billions and billions of dollars to
these skates
it was also a way of getting a lot of
money from our people's pockets to
people that come into our country
illegally we were going to take care of
everything for them
and what that does and i'd love to do
that i'd love to help them but what that
does
everybody all over the world will start
pouring into our country we can't do it
this was a way of taking care of
them this was a way of spending on
things that had nothing to do with covet
as per your question
but it was really a big bailout for
badly run
democrat cities and states all right if
i get elected i'm not going to i'm
running as a proud democrat i'm going to
be an american president
i don't see red states and blue states
what i see
is american united states and folks
every single state out there
finds themselves in trouble they're
going to start laying off whether
they're red or blue
cops firefighters first responders
because
teachers because they have to balance
their budget and the founders were smart
they allowed the federal government to
deficit spend to compensate
for the united states of america i want
to talk about the minimum wage gentlemen
mr vice president
we are talking a lot about struggling
small businesses
and business owners these days do you
think this is the right time to ask them
to raise the minimum wage you of course
support a 15
federal minimum i do because i think one
of the things we're going to have to do
is we're going to have to bail them out
too
we should be bailing them out now those
small businesses
you got one in six of them going under
they're not going to be able to make it
back
they passed the pro a package that
allows us
to be able to call ppp money's supposed
to go to help them do everything from
organize how they can deal with their
businesses being open safely
schools how they can make classrooms
smaller how they can hire more
teachers how they can put ventilation
systems in they
need the help the businesses as well as
the schools need the help
but this because these guys will not
help them it's not giving them any of
the money
we are going to move on to immigration
but i want to say we have to work for
small businesses
by raising the minimum wage that's not
helping i i think it should be a state
option
alabama is different than new york new
york is different from vermont
every state is different it should be a
state app you said we have to help
it's very important we have to help our
small businesses how are you helping
your small businesses when you're
forcing wages
what's going to happen and what's been
proven to happen is when you do that
these small businesses
fire many of their employees you said
very recently you would consider
raising the federal minimum wage to 15
an hour you said recently you would
consider raising the federal minimum
wage
an hour that's still the case and i
would consider it in it to an extent but
it's a really long
in a second administration but not to a
level that's going to put all these
businesses out of business
it should be a state option look
everything in different places i know
different places they're all different
some places 15 is not so bad
in other places other states fifteen
dollars okay president trump thank you
quick response vice president two jobs
one
job be low poverty
people are making six seven eight bucks
an hour these first responders
we all clap for as they come down the
street because they've allowed us to
make it
what's happening they deserve a minimum
wage of fifteen dollars
anything below that puts you below the
poverty level and there is no evidence
that when you raise
the minimum wage businesses go out of
business that is simply
not true we're going to talk about
immigration we're going to talk about
immigration now gentlemen
and we're going to talk about families
within this context mr president your
administration
separated children from their parents at
the border at least four
thousand kids you've since reversed your
zero tolerance policy
but the united states can't locate the
parents of more than 500 children
so how will these families ever be
reunited children
are brought here by coyotes and lots of
bad people
cartels and they're brought here and
they used to use them to get into our
country
we now have as strong a border as we've
ever had
we're over 400 miles of brand new wall
you see the numbers and we let people in
but they have to come in legally and
they come in through but how will you
reunite let me just tell you guys with
their family
they built cages you know they used to
say i built the cages
and then they had a picture in a certain
newspaper
and it was a picture of these horrible
cages and they said look at these cages
president trump built them and then it
was determined they were built
in 2014. that was him they built him to
reunite the kids yes we're working on it
very
we're trying very hard but a lot of
these kids come out without the parents
they come over through cartels and
through coyotes and through gangs
vice president let me bring you into
this conversation quick response and
then another question to you these 500
plus kids came
with parents they separated them at the
border
to make it a disincentive to come to
begin with
they real tough we're really strong and
guess what
they cannot it's not coyotes didn't
bring them over their
parents were with them they got
separated from their parents
and it makes us a laughing stock and
violates every notion of who we are
as a nation let me ask you a friend they
did it
we changed the policy your response they
did it we just did not
they built the cages they who built the
cages
let's talk about who built the cages
let's talk about what we're talking
about
what happened parents were ripped their
kids were ripped from their arms
and separated and now they cannot find
over 500 of
sets of those parents and those kids are
alone
nowhere to go nowhere to go it's
criminal
it's criminal let me ask listen i will
say this they went down
we brought reporters everything they are
so
well taken care of they're in facilities
that were so clean
some of them haven't been reunited but
just ask one question
who built the cages i'd love you to ask
him that who built the cages
let me ask about your immigration policy
mr vice president the obama
administration did fail to deliver
immigration reform which had been a key
promise during the administration it
also presided over record deportations
as well as family detentions at the
border before changing course
so why should voters trust you with an
immigration overhaul now
because you made a mistake it made two
it took too long to get it right
it took too long to get it right i'll be
president united states not vice
president united states and the fact is
i've made it very clear
within 100 days i'm going to send to the
united states congress
a pathway to citizenship for over 11
million undocumented people
and all of those so-called dreamers
those daca kids they're going to be
immediately certified again to be able
to stay
in this country and put on a path to
citizenship the idea that
they are being sent home by this guy and
they want to do that
is they've gone to a country they've
never seen before i can imagine you're
five years old your parents are taking
it across
the rio grande river and is
and it's illegal and you say oh no mom
leave me here i'm not going to go with
you
they've been here many of my models said
over twenty thousand
are first responders out there taking
care of people during this crisis
we owe them we owe them
he had eight years to do what he said he
was going to do
and i've changed without having a
specific
we got rid of catch and release we got
rid of a lot of
horrible things that they put in and
that they lived with
but he had eight years he was vice
president he
did nothing except build cages
to keep children in vice president your
response
the catch and release you know what he's
talking about there if in fact you had
a family came across and they were
arrested
they in fact were given a date to show
up for their hearing
they were released and guess what they
showed up for a hearing
this is the first president in history
united states america that's anybody
seeking asylum has to do it in another
country
that's never happened before in america
that's never happened before in america
you come to the united states and you
make your case that i
seek asylum based on the following on
the following premise
why i deserve it under american law
they're sitting in squalor on the other
side of the river
president trump your response show him
seconds it just shows that he has no
understanding of immigration of the laws
catch and release is a disaster
a murderer would come in a rapist would
come in
a very bad person would come in we would
take their name
we have to release them into our country
and then you say they come back less
than one percent of the people
come back we have to send ice out and
border patrol out to find them
we would say come back in two years
three years
we're going to give you a court case you
need perry mason we're going to give you
a court case
when you say they come back they don't
come back joe they never come back
only the really i hate to say this
but those with the lowest iq they might
come back okay president trump let's
give vice president biden a chance to
respond and then we're going to move on
to this you don't know the law joe
vice president biden your response know
the law what he's telling you is simply
not true
well check it out they don't come back
check it out all right let's move but we
don't have to worry about it because i
terminated it so we'd have to worry
about it that's right
yeah 525 kids not knowing where in god's
name they're going to be and lost their
parents go ahead
all right let's talk about our next
section which is
race in america and i want to talk about
the way black and brown americans
experience race in this country part of
that experience
is something called the talk it happens
regardless of class
and income parents who feel they have no
choice
but to prepare their children for the
chance that they could be targeted
including by the police for no reason
other than the color of their skin
mr vice president in the next two
minutes i want you to speak
directly to these families do you
understand why these parents
fear for their children i do i do
you know my daughter is a social worker
and uh
she's all she's written a lot about this
she has a graduate degree from the
university of pennsylvania in social
work
and you know uh one of the reasons why i
ended up working on the east side of
wilmington
delaware which is 90 african american
was to learn more about what was going
on what i didn't i never had to tell my
daughter
if she's pulled over make sure she puts
for a
traffic stop put both hands on top of
the wheel and don't reach for the glove
box because someone may shoot you
but a black parent no matter how wealthy
or how poor they are
has to teach their child when you're
walking down the street
don't have a hoodie on when you go
across the street making sure
that you in fact if you get pulled over
yes
yes sir no sir hands on top of the wheel
because
you are in fact the victim whether
you're a person making
300 child of a 300 000 a year person or
someone who's on
on on food stamps the fact of the matter
is
there is institutional racism america
and we
have always said we've never lived up to
it do we hold these truths to be
self-evident
all men and women are created equal well
guess what we
have never ever lived up to but we've
all constantly been moving the needle
further and further
to inclusion not exclusion this is the
first president to come along and says
that's the end of that
we're not going to do that anymore we
have to provide for economic opportunity
better education better health care
better access to
schooling better access to opportunity
to
borrow money to start businesses all the
things we can do and i've laid out a
clear
plan as to how to do those things just
to give people a shot
it's about accumulating the ability to
have wealth as well as it is
to be free from violence president trump
same question to you and let me remind
you of the question i would like you to
speak
directly to these families do you
understand why these parents fear for
their children yes i do
and again he's been in government 47
years he never did a thing except in
1994 when he did such
harm to the black community and they
were called and he called them super
predators
and he said that he said it's super
predators
and they kept never lived that down 1994
your crime bill the super predators
nobody has done more for the black
community than donald trump and if you
look
with the exception of abraham lincoln
possible exception but the exception of
abraham lincoln
nobody has done what i've done criminal
justice reform
obama and joe didn't do it
i don't even think they tried because
they had no chance at doing it
they might have wanted to do it but if
you had to see the arms i had a twist to
get that done
it was not a pretty picture and
everybody knows it including some very
liberal people that
cried in my office they cried in the
oval office two weeks later they're out
saying gee we have to defeat him
criminal justice reform prison reform
opportunity zones with tim scott a great
senator from
south carolina he came in with this
incredible idea for opportunity zones
it's one of the most successful programs
people don't talk about it tremendous
investment is being made biggest
beneficiary
the black and hispanic communities and
then historically black
colleges and universities after three
years of coming to the office
i love some of those guys they were
great they came into the office
and they said i said what are you doing
after three years i said why do you keep
coming back
because we have no funding i said you
don't have to come back every year we
have to come back
because president obama would never give
them long-term funding
and i did 10-year long-term funding
and i gave them more money than they
asked for because they said i think you
need more
and i said the only bad part about this
is i may never see you again because
i got very friendly with them and they
like me and i like them
but i saved colleges and universities
okay
and we're going to talk about both of
your records but your response to that
vice president my response to that is i
never ever said what he accused me of
saying the fact of the matter is in 2000
though
after the crime bill had been in in in
in the law for a while
this is the guy who said the problem
with the crime bill there's not enough
people in jail
there's not enough people in jail and go
on my website get the quote the date
when he said it
not enough people he talked about
marauding gangs
young gangs and the people who were
going to maraude our cities
this is a guy who in the central park
five five innocent black kids he
continued to push for making sure
that they got the death penalty none of
them were none of them
were guilty of what the crime of the
crimes they were
suggested look and talk about he granted
he did in fact let 20 people he commuted
20 people sentences
we commuted over a thousand people's
sentences over a thousand
the very law he's talking about is a law
that in fact
initiated by barack obama and secondly
we're in a situation here where we the
federal prison system was reduced by
38 000 people under our administration
and one of these things we should be
doing there should be no
no minimum mandatories in the law that's
why i'm offering
20 billion dollars of states to change
their state laws
to eliminate minimum mandatories and set
up drug courts no one should be going to
jail
because they have a drug problem they
should be going to rehabilitation
not to jail we should fundamentally
change the system and that's what i'm
going to do
but why didn't he do it four years ago
why didn't you do that
four years ago even less than that why
didn't i when you were vice president
you keep talking about all these things
you're going to do and you're going to
do this
but you were there just a short time ago
and you guys did nothing
we did you know joe i i ran because of
you i ran because of barack obama
because you did a poor job if i thought
you did a good job i would have never
run
i would have never run i ran because of
you i'm looking at you now you're a
politician
i ran because of you all right vice
president biden your response to that
and then i do have some questions for
both of you well i'll tell you what
i uh i hope he does look at me because
what's happening here is
you know who i am you know who he is
you know his character you know my
character you know our reputations for
honor and telling the truth
i am anxious to have this race i am
anxious to see this
take place i am the character of the
country
is on the ballot our character is in the
ballot look at us closely
let me ask some folks please respond
we're gonna have stuff that's true
about russia ukraine china other
countries
iraq if this is true then he's a corrupt
politician right
so don't give me the stuff about how
you're this innocent baby
joe they're calling you a corrupt
politician nobody's president trump
i want to stay on the issue of race
we're talking about
from hell president trump talking about
race right now and i do want to stay
on the issue of race president trump i
have to respond to that please
look very quick there are 50 former
national intelligence folks
who said that what this he's accusing me
of is a russian
plan they have said that this is has all
the care
four five former heads of the cia both
parties
say what he's saying is a bunch of
garbage nobody believes it except
of his and his good friend rudy gianni
you mean the laptop is
now another russia russia russia hoax
that's exactly what
this is exactly what this is where he's
going the laptop
is russia russia i want to stay on the
issue of race you have to be kidding me
here we go again with russia
we're going to continue on the issue of
race mr president you've described
the black lives matter movement as a
symbol of hate
you've shared a video of a man chanting
white power to millions of your
supporters
you've said that black professional
athletes exercising their first
amendment rights should be fired
what do you say to americans who say
that kind of language from a president
is contributing to a climate of hate and
racial strife well you have to
understand the first time i ever heard
of black lives matter
they were chanting pigs in a blanket
talking about police
pigs pigs talking about our police pigs
in a blanket
fry them like bacon i said that's a
horrible thing and they were marching
down the street
and that was my first glimpse of black
lives matter i thought it was a terrible
thing
as far as my relationships with
all people i think i have great
relationships with all people
i am the least racist person in this
room
what do you say to americans who are
concerned by that rhetoric i don't know
i mean i don't know what to say i got
criminal justice reform done and prison
reform and opportunity zones i took care
of black
colleges and universities i don't know
what to say
they can say anything i mean they can
say anything
it's a very it makes me sad because i am
i am the least racist person i can't
even see the audience because it's so
dark
but i don't care who's in the audience
i'm the least racist person in this room
okay vice president biden let me ask you
very quickly and then i have a follow-up
question for you
abraham lincoln here is one of the most
racist presidents we've had in modern
history
he pours fuel on every single
racist fire every single one started off
his campaign coming down the escalator
saying he's going to get rid of those
mexican rapists he's banned muslims
because they're muslims
he has moved around and made everything
worse
across the board he says to about the
poor boys
last time we were on stage here he said
i told him to stand down
and stand ready come on this guy is a
dog whistle about as big as a foghorn
president trump i'm going to give you 10
seconds to respond and then i have a
follow-up he made a reference to abraham
lincoln where did that come in
i mean you said you're abraham i know
where did that no
no you said i said not since abraham
lincoln
has anybody done what i've done for the
black community and i'm saying
you say i'm abraham lincoln i said not
since
abraham lincoln has anybody done what
i've done for the black
community now you have done nothing
other than the crime bill
which put oh god uh tens of thousands
of black men mostly in jail all right
you know what yeah let me remember vice
president you look at what's happening
with the voting right now
let me ask you they remember president i
treated them very very
badly just take a look at what's
happening out there vice president biden
let me give you a chance to respond
within this context crime bills that you
supported in the 80s and 90s
contributed to the incarceration of tens
of thousands of young black men
who had small amounts of drugs in their
possession they are sons they are
brothers their fathers their uncles
whose families are still to this day
some of them suffering the consequences
so speak to those families why should
they vote for you one of the things is
that in the 80s we passed
100 all 100 senators voted for it
a bill on drugs and how to deal with
drugs it was a mistake
i've been trying to change the since
then particularly the portion on cocaine
that's why i've been arguing that in
fact we should not
send anyone to jail for a
pure drug offense they should be going
into treatment
across the board that's what we should
be spending money that's why i set up
drug courts which were never funded
by republican friends they should not be
going to jail
for a drug or an alcohol problem they
should be going into
treatment treatment that's what we've
been trying to do that's what i'm going
to get done
because i think the american people have
now seen
that in fact it was a mistake to pass
those laws relating to the drug
but they were not in the crime bill but
why didn't he get it done see
it's all talk no action with his
politicians why didn't he get it done
that's what i'm gonna do when i become
president you were vice president
along with obama as your president your
leader for eight years
why didn't you get it done you had eight
years to get it done now you're saying
you're gonna get it done
because you're all talk and no action we
got a lot of it done we released 38.
anything got 38 000 prisoners left you
got
nothing done 38 000 prisoners were
released from federal prison
we have there were over a thousand
people who were given clemency
we make fact we're the ones that put in
the legislation saying
we could look at pattern and practice of
police departments and what they were
doing
how they were conducting themselves i
could go on but we began the process
we began the process we lost an election
that's why i'm running
to win back that election and change his
terrible policies i just haven't heard
the number one question why didn't
you do it in the eight years a short
time ago
why didn't you do it you just said i'm
going to do that i'm going to do this
you put tens of thousands of mostly
black young men in prison now you're
saying you're going to get
you're going to undo that why didn't you
get it done you had eight years with
obama
you know why joe because you're all talk
and no action all right vice president
biden and then we're going to move on to
the next section
we've got a republican congress
that's the answer okay look you got to
talk them into it
so all right you gotta talk him into it
we're gonna move on to our next section
like i did with
criminal justice reform i had to talk
democrats into
gentlemen you're dead we're running out
of time so we gotta get on to
climate change please you both have very
different visions
on climate change president trump you
say that environmental regulations have
hurt jobs in the energy sector
vice president biden you have said you
see addressing climate change
as an opportunity to create new jobs for
each of you
how would you both combat climate change
and support job growth at the same time
starting with you president trump you
have two minutes uninterrupted
so we have the trillion trees program
we have so many different programs i do
love the environment but what i want is
the cleanest crystal clear water
the cleanest air we have the best lowest
number in carbon
emissions which is a big standard that i
notice obama goes with all the time
not joe i haven't heard joe use the term
because i'm not sure he knows what it
represents or means but i have heard
obama use it
and we have the best carbon emission
numbers that we've had in 35 years
under this administration we are working
so well with industry but
here's what we can't do look at china
how filthy it is
look at russia look at india it's
filthy the the air is filthy
the paris accord i took us out because
we were going to have to spend
trillions of dollars and we were treated
very unfairly
when they put us in there they did us a
great disservice they were going to take
away our businesses
i will not sacrifice tens of millions of
jobs
thousands and thousands of companies
because of
the paris accord it was so unfair china
doesn't kick in
until 2030. russia goes back to a low
standard
and we kicked in right away it would
have been it would have been it would
have destroyed our businesses so
you ready we have done an incredible job
environmentally
we have the cleanest air the cleanest
water and the best carbon emission
standards
that we've seen in many many years vice
president
we haven't destroyed our industries vice
president biden two minutes to you
uninterrupted climate change and climate
warming
global warming is an existential threat
to humanity
we have a moral obligation to deal with
it
and we're told by all the leading
scientists in the world we don't have
much time we're going to pass the point
of no return
within the next eight to ten years four
more years of this man
eliminating all the regulations that
were put in by us
to clean up the climate to clean up to
limit
the the limit of emissions will put us
in a position where we're going to be in
real
trouble here's where we have a great
opportunity i was able to get
both all the environmental organizations
as well as labor
the people worried about jobs to support
my
climate plan because what it does it
will create
millions of new good paying jobs we're
going to invest
in for example five hundred thousand
fifty thousand fifty thousand charging
stations
on our highways so that we can own the
electric car market of the future
in the meantime china is doing that
we're going to be in a position where
we're going to see to it
that we're going to take 4 million
existing billion
buildings and 2 million existing homes
and retrofit them so they don't leak as
much energy
saving hundreds of millions of barrels
of oil in the process
and creating significant number of jobs
and by the way
the whole idea of what this is all going
to do it's going to create
millions of jobs and it's going to clean
the environment our health
and our jobs are at stake that's what's
happening
and what right now by the way wall
street firms indicated that
my plan my my plan will in fact create
18.6 million jobs 7 million more than
his this is from wall street
and i'll create one trillion dollars
more in economic growth
than his proposal does not on climate
just on the economy
president trump came out and said very
strongly
five hundred dollars will be taken away
from families under his plan
that his plan is an economic disaster if
you look at what he wants to do you know
the
if you look at his plan his
environmental plan you know who
developed it
aoc plus three they know nothing
about the climate i mean she's got a
good line of stuff but she knows nothing
about the climate
and they're all hopping through hoops
for aoc plus three
look their real plan cost a hundred
trillion dollars
if we had the best year in the history
of our country for a hundred years
we would not even come close to a number
like that
when he says buildings they want to take
buildings down because i want to make
bigger windows into smaller windows
as far as they're concerned if you had
no window it would be a lovely thing
this is the craziest plan that anybody
has ever seen
and this wasn't done by smart people
this wasn't done
by anybody frankly i don't even know how
it can be good politically
they want to spend a hundred trillion
dollars that's their real number he's
trying to say it was six
it's a hundred trillion dollars they
want to knock down buildings and build
new buildings with little
tiny small windows i mean and many other
things okay and many other things let me
have the vice president respond and
we're running out of time and we have a
lot more questions
so let's hear from the vice president i
have a number of more questions i don't
know where he comes from
i don't know where he comes up with
these numbers weighing 100
trillion dollars give me a break
this plan was this is planned endorsed
by every major
every major environmental group and
every labor group
labor because they know the future lies
the future lies and thus being able to
breathe and they know they're good jobs
in getting us there
and by the way the fastest growing
industry in america
are is is is the electric
the excuse me solar energy and wind
he thinks wind causes cancer windmills
it's the fastest growing
jobs and they pay good prevailing wages
45-50 bucks an hour we can
grow and we can be cleaner if we go
the route i'm proposing president trump
please respond
we are energy independent for the first
time
we don't need all of these countries
that we had to fight war over because we
needed their energy
we are energy independent i know more
about wind than you do
it's extremely expensive kills all the
birds
it's very intermittent it's got a lot of
problems and they happen to make the
windmills in both germany and china
and the fumes coming up if you're a
believer in carbon emission
the fumes coming up to make make these
massive windmills
is more than anything that we're talking
about with natural gas which is very
clean one other thing
find me a solar system i love solar but
solar doesn't quite have it yet
it's not powerful in it yet to to really
run our big
beautiful factories that we need to
compete with the world
so far it's all a pipe dream but you
know what we'll do
we're going to have the greatest economy
in the world but if you want to kill the
economy get rid of your oil industry
you want and and what about fracking all
right let me know let me have you
let me allow vice president to respond
never said
i oppose frackie you said it on tape i
did show the tape put it on your website
i'll put it on put it on the website the
fact of the matter is
flat lying would you rule out banning
fracking
i do rule out benny fracking because the
answer we need
we need other industries
to transition to get to ultimately a
complete
zero emissions by 2025. what i will do
with fracking over time
is make sure that we can capture the
emissions
from the fracking capture the emissions
from gas
we can do that and we can do that by
investing money
and doing it but it's a transition to
that i have one more question in this
position
it was against fracking he said it i
will show that to you tomorrow
i am against fracking until he got the
nomination went to pennsylvania then he
said
but you know what pennsylvania he'll be
against it very soon because his party
is totally against fracking on federal
land i said no fracking or oil
let me ask this final question in this
section and then i want to move on to
our final
section president trump people of color
are much more likely to live near oil
refineries and chemical plants
in texas there are families who worry
the plants near them are
making them sick your administration has
rolled back regulations on these kinds
of facilities
why should these families give you
another four years in office
the families that we're talking about
are employed heavily and they're making
a lot of money more money than they've
ever made
if you look at the kind of numbers that
we produce for hispanic
or black for asian it's nine times
greater the percentage gain
than it was under in three years than it
was under
eight years of the two of them
to put it nicely nine times more
now somebody lives i have not heard the
numbers or the state
statistics that you're saying but
they're making a tremendous amount of
money
economically we saved it and i saved it
again a number of months ago when oil
was crashing because of the pandemic
we saved it we got say what you want
about relationship we got saudi arabia
mexico and russia to cut back way back
we saved our oil industry and now it's
very vibrant together and everybody has
very inexpensive gasoline
vice president biden your response and
then we're going to have a final
question for both of you my response is
that those people live on what they call
fence lines she doesn't understand this
they live near chemical plants that in
fact pollute
chemical plants and oil plants and
refineries the pollute
i used to live near that when i was
growing up in clemont delaware
and all the more oral refineries in
marcus hook and the delaware river than
there is
any place including in houston at the
time when my mom get in the car
and when it when their first frost to
drive me to school turned in the
windshield but there'd be oil slick in
the window
that's why so many people in my state
were dying and getting cancer
the fact is those front line communities
it doesn't matter what you're paying
them it matters
how you keep them safe what do you do
and you impose restrictions on the
pollutions
that the pollutants coming out of those
fence line
communities okay i have one final would
he close down there
it falls or would you close down the
earth by the way i would transition from
the oil ministry yes
oh transition it is a big statement
because
i would stop why would you do that
because the oil industry
pollutes significantly i said here's the
deal but
that's a big statement well if you let
me finish the statement
because it has to be replaced by
renewable energy
over time over time and i'd stop giving
to the oil industry i'd stop giving them
federal subsidies
you won't give federal subsidies to the
to the gas
exchange to the uh to uh solar and wind
yeah why are we giving it to oil
industry we actually do
solar and wind that's maybe the biggest
statement in terms of business
that's the biggest thing because
basically what he's saying is he is
going to destroy
the oil industry will you remember that
texas would you remember that
pennsylvania oklahoma vice president
biden let me give you 10 seconds to
respond and i have to get to the final
question
vice president biden he takes everything
out of context but the point is look
we have to move toward a net zero
emissions
the first place to do that by the year
2035 is in energy production
by 2050 totally all right is he going to
get china to do it no we're finished
with this is he going to get china to
our final question
i'm going to rejoin paris accord to make
china abide by what they agreed to
all right this is about leadership
gentlemen and this
first question does go to you president
trump
imagine this is your inauguration day
what will you say
in your america to americans who did not
vote for you
you'll each have one minute starting
with you we have to make
a country totally successful as it was
prior to the plague coming in from china
now we're rebuilding it and we're doing
record numbers 11.4 million
jobs in a short period of time etc but i
will tell you go back
before the plague came in just before i
was getting calls from people that were
not normally people that would call me
they wanted to get together we had the
best
black unemployment numbers in the
history of our country
hispanic women asian
people with diplomas with no diplomas
mit graduates number one in the class
everybody had the best numbers and you
know what the other side
wanted to get together they wanted to
unify success is going to bring us
together
we are on the road to success but i'm
cutting taxes
and he wants to raise everybody's taxes
and he wants to put new regulations on
everything he will kill it
if he gets in you will have a depression
the likes of which you've never seen
your 401ks will go to hell and it'll be
a very very sad day for this country
all right vice president biden same
question to you what will you say during
your inaugural address to americans who
did not vote for you
i will say i'm an american president
i represent all of you whether you voted
for me or against me
and i'm going to make sure that you're
represented i'm going to give you hope
we're going to move we're going to
choose science over fiction
we're going to choose hope over fear
we're going to choose to move forward
because we have enormous
opportunities enormous opportunities to
make things better
we can grow this economy we can deal
with systemic racism
and at the same time we can make sure
that our economy
is being run and moved and motivated by
clean energy creating millions of new
jobs
and that's the fact that's what we're
going to do and i'm going to say
as i said in the beginning what is on
the ballot here
is the character of this country decency
honor respect treating people with
dignity
making sure that everyone has an even
chance and i'm going to make sure you
get that
you haven't been getting it the last
four years all right
i want to thank you both for a very
robust hour and a half a fantastic
debate
really appreciate it president trump
former vice president joe biden
thank you to belmont university for
hosting us tonight and most importantly
thank you to those watching tonight
election day is november 3rd
don't forget to vote thank you everyone
and have a great night
so
thank you
i